Buon pomeriggio a tutti qualcuno mi dice
che la memoria permane attraverso le
storie Allora io parlo della mia storia
parto così oggi Mi chiamo Valentina e da
bambina Sognavo di insegnare già le
vedevo le immagini impresse in cui
coloro che mi sentivano dire vorrò
insegnare da grande e lo dice no
rischierai la fame
rischierai la fame e nel contempo mentre
sognavo mi divertivo in quel Lembo di
terra Friulana del mio nonno e lui
coltivava dove era i suoi frutti poi si
andava nei boschi insieme a coltivare a
raccogliere i porcini e mi diceva sai
questo è il mio motto Valentina
nell'imperfezione si cela La vera
bellezza
Però io rimanevo un attimo così attonita
perché dicevo Sì però non c'è
competizione vado al supermercato me li
trovo puliti belli quei frutti quei
funghi e di questo i miei studenti non
se ne capacitàvano loro credevano che
tutto crescesse nella busta in
particolar modo Mario che mi è rimasto
nel cuore Mario perché Mario l'unico
fungo che nella vita aveva visto era
quello di Super Mario Bros allora lì
capimmo come scuola come istituzione che
avremmo dovuto fare qualcosa allora
Chiamammo degli studenti di agraria E
insomma
insieme
progettando e costruiamo un e andremo a
costruire un orto un orto e Mario iniziò
a sperimentare che cosa volesse dire
vedere la crescita le
di un frutto vedete Io ho capito una
cosa che in questi anni di insegnamento
non sono le risposte a di svelare il
mondo ma sono le domande che noi
lasciamo che ti svelano il mondo se io
avessi risposto a Mario ora non farebbe
l'ingegnere ambientale e progetta spazi
però vedete c'è anche chi questa
esperienza non l'ha vissuta e qui faccio
riferimento a dei fenomeni giovanili e
mi riferisco per esempio agli Health
cioè gli erli Liver from Education and
training che secondo dati eurostat al
2020 stiamo parlando di ragazzi nella
scuola secondaria di primo e di secondo
grado che decidono di abbandonare gli
studi e Questo poi è predittivo dei neet
che sempre a dati 2020 ci parlano di 3
milioni di giovani che ne sono occupati
e ne sono iscritti a un percorso di
formazione di istruzione Potrei
continuare andando avanti parlando degli
hikikomori per esempio dai cosiddetti
ritirati sociali di cui Mario di cui
Marco Scusate Crepaldi parla ci dice che
sono 100.000 intorno questi casi Ma c'è
anche
interroghiamoci quindi uno spaccato
giovanile quello sensibile Cioè voi io
di fronte giovani sensibili alla
sostenibilità ambientale certo Greta
thunberg in questo ha fatto un lavoro
eccezionale ha saputo portare le grida
dei giovani all'interno delle
istituzioni le stesse istituzioni che
molto spesso si aggirano a livelli
minimi di partecipazione giovanile e
questi sono giovani per noi fondamentali
sono il faro e il passo da cui muovere
però non sono sufficienti cioè la
minaccia di estinzione del genere umano
non è stata sufficiente così efficace
per generare un comportamento che sia
quello che va da verso il rallentamento
di questo riscaldamento rallentamento
che potrebbe essere inteso come di
adattamento mitigazione qui non sto a
disquisire sulle differenze però se quei
ragazzi in quella frangente a cui non
avessimo risposto Che cosa è la crescita
Allora forse sarebbero stati lì Lì in
quella minaccia in quella minaccia di
estinzione e Allora vedete c'è proprio
questo scollamento per cui la scienza
fatica a comunicare il rischio globale
poi c'è però chi Quel rischio globale lo
vive sulla propria pelle quei giovani
dispersi coloro che perdono la dignità
di tutti loro coloro che lo sentono
sulla loro pelle
e noi lo ignoriamo perché Diciamoci la
verità che se non fosse stato per
elencare bollette non so quanti in
qualche modo
avrebbero scelto di spegnere la luce per
una appartenenza comunitaria E allora
qual è questo Gap mancante tra la
transizione ecologica e quei giovani che
sono estraniati dalla natura il gapè la
mancanza di desiderio Cioè abbiamo
consegnato a loro l'immagine
catastrofica del futuro ma l'istituzioni
formative educative devono fare ancora
di più non hanno fatto ancora abbastanza
per consegnare loro la cassetta degli
attrezzi che permetta a loro di abitare
in modo nuovo la terra non è solo
abitare consumo perché vedete in quelle
percentuali di giovani che vi dicevo non
sono solo quelli ma sono sono anche
quelli presenti in aula Ma i quali
fatica la conoscenza impattare nella
realtà se poi non si traduce in uno
stile di vita sostenibile Allora
l'istituzione educativa è fondamentale
come driver di processo di cambiamento
perché sapete Mario quel famoso Mario
che ritorna non aveva avuto molto in
eredità perché la transizione ecologica
va di pari passo con l'innovazione E
allora Vi propongo un'altra prospettiva
oggi Io penso che per innovare dobbiamo
scegliere che cosa ereditare cioè quei
giovani
dispersi abbandonati assenti con la
mente presenti che cosa ereditano
l'eredità virtuale solo questa no non è
sufficiente il contesto in cui ha
vissuto Mario gli ha permesso
quel riscatto Guarda che oltre a quel
fungo lì che tu vedi C'è anche questo è
l'istituzione che non ha detto Colpa
della famiglia
Gli ha insegnato a chiudere l'acqua a
fare le differenziata No sono io
istituzione che ti dico e ti do
un'esperienza quindi Mario ha scelto che
cosa ereditare se la natura come
esperienza oppure il dispositivo come
risposte quelle risposte a cui noi
tendiamo sempre invece sono le domande e
Allora vedete
per rendere desiderabile la transizione
ecologica dobbiamo prima provare a dire
l'acqua quando scorre
L'erba quando cresce dobbiamo prima
provare a sentirci impauriti
dall'imbrunire del cielo in cui ti si
sente piccoli così finiti essere finiti
finitudine umana paura solo quando
proverò questo allora potrò desiderare
altro perché vedete la transizione
ecologica
parla di valori ecologici ma quando poi
si parla del corpo umano che è finito
lì dove sono i valori ecologici vogliamo
oltrepassare i limiti vogliamo far sì
che questa tecnologia ci liberi dalle
costrizioni del nostro corpo e quindi
penso la potenziazione umana che per la
cura ha un senso ma quell'imperfezione
che mi tramandava mio nonno mi diceva lì
in quell'imperfezione ce l'aveva la
bellezza perché Diciamoci la verità che
è molto più semplice
nasconderci dietro questa tecnologia che
ci illude della nostra
onnipotenza
rispetto invece a comprendere che siamo
finiti che quindi abbiamo bisogno
dell'altro abbiamo bisogno di te che
spegni la luce perché altrimenti io qui
non sopravvivo
E allora
ho chiesto Mario Ma allora Mario Secondo
te cos'è che merita di essere ereditato
in un futuro
e lui mi ha detto i luoghi della memoria
quelli in cui ho imparato a sperimentare
quelli per cui ho imparato a vivere
perché noi non siamo nati videocentrici
ci serve Sì ma noi siamo nati cinque
sensi Quindi abbiamo bisogno di
ritornare a quel richiamo lì per dire
che allora la tecnologia può essere
umanizzata E allora quando lui progetta
questi spazi pone sempre delle domande a
questa comunità quanto mi permette di
cambiare le mie condizioni di vita a chi
quell'eredità non ce l'ha quanto glielo
permette di cambiare a quello comunità
quanto questa comunità mi permette di
coltivare la spiritualità ecologica
e quanto mi permette di partecipare alla
vita naturale e non solo anche culturale
anche i beni materiali
quanto mi permette di partecipare Ecco
allora qui è nella costruzione di una
capacità di una comunità capacitàtante
che compensa quelle eredità che io non
ho ricevuto solo quando le istituzioni
insieme potranno andare a compensare
ibridarsi per dire ti do anche questo in
eredità e non solo virtuale perché
vedete sicuramente la tecnologia ci
potrà salvare da questa catastrofe ma ci
potrà salvare in modo autentico solo
quando non sarà soltanto tecnologia
perché
là dove c'è il pericolo cresce anche ciò
che salva grazie
[Applauso]